[Musique]
ap des pôles à la rescousse ça n'arrive
pas tous les jours mais quand il est
question de se débarrasser d'une
infestation de limaces il n'y a pas de
meilleur exterminatrice solde de base
les limaces et leurs préférés elles sont
vraiment abondante à calgary cette année
affirme ariel muriel par girts
l'entrepreneur derrière le projet mais
elle mange de tout dit elle
mais dans doctrine des pucerons des
fourmis bref n'importe quel insecte en
deux visites d'une heure et demie et
nous nettoierons votre jardin se
rempliront la panse et s'il n'hésite pas
à se donner un coup d'aile pour avoir
accès aux meilleures plates bandes
les poules sont aussi très heureuse dans
des bras chaleureux pour la famille à
bobby sweet c'est un véritable
divertissement
j'adore ce surtout qu'un épi corps mes
bras vous l'avez jamais de la famille
pour nous c'est l'idéal affirme sa mère
on extermine les limaces et au bénéficie
des effets thérapeutiques d'abord des
poules qui s'endorment dans nos bras
si avant tout ce genre de rencontres qui
motive ariel à poursuivre l'aventuré
j'aime beaucoup que mes poules fasse
plaisir aux gens tirent marielle
particulièrement une année comme celle
ci où tout le monde a besoin d'un peu
plus de sourires il faudrait neveu
radio-canada kagari
[Musique]